if you were waiting for prey good news  it just got an official release date I'm  Tony in this game spot news update is  just a few months away pray launches  worldwide on xbox one ps4 and PC on May  fib this was revealed in the latest  trailer featuring new narration from  protagonist Morgan you we also learned  that Morgan was involved in alien  experiments and now has to stop the  creatures before they attack earth  you'll have to use a bunch of different  weapons and psychic powers to pull that  off prey is also getting a pre-order  bonus the cosmonaut shotgun pack  includes Morgan's family shotgun to med  kits 3 neuro mods for upgrades and a  starter kit for crafting tools and  weapons you should expect plenty more  info on pray in the coming months and to  keep up with all of it you're already in  the right place